la ciudad de bucha fue una de las
poblaciones al norte de la ciudad de
kiev que vivió una mayor destrucción
sino la que vivió la mayor destrucción
cuando aquí estuvieron las tropas rusas
después de la invasión el 24 de febrero
ellas estuvieron aquí hasta finales de
marzo y no solamente dejaron más de 400
personas muertas sino parte de la ciudad
destruida y también toda su
infraestructura no solamente eléctrica
de calefacción sino también todo su
acceso a las redes de comunicación
especialmente a los celulares desde que
partieron las autoridades locales como
las autoridades estatales han estado
reparando estos servicios que venían
funcionando más o menos bien también
habían estado reparando muchísimas de
las viviendas cuatrocientas viviendas
privadas algunos edificios
gubernamentales y el 80% de la población
se dice había regresado es una población
de 80.000 habitantes sin embargo todo
esto vuelve a quedar en en el Limbo
desde estos ataques de a los servicios y
a la red energética ucraniana hecha por
las fuerzas rusas especialmente el de la
semana pasada los cortes eléctricos han
vuelto a la ciudad a pesar de que las
autoridades están haciendo todo lo
posible por importar generadores
eléctricos hay uno bastante grande en el
centro al cual están tratando de unir
toda la red eléctrica pero faltan muchos
otros lugares de la ciudad para
proveerlos y ellos también están
intentando Cómo dar calefacción muchas
de las viviendas privadas están unidas a
la red eléctrica así que están buscando
alternativas en una carrera contra el
tiempo Ellos dicen que vienen más
generadores están creando espacios de
calor y espacios donde las personas se
pueden proteger en los momentos más
duros del Invierno pero como en otras
ciudades de Ucrania también están
esperando nuevos ataques especialmente a
la infraestructura